big dude who was smoking the cigarette
you know took off his shirt to one let
that
one let's drag up the cigarette didn't
know how to fight you could see
when he went with his feet the back way
and what happened right away when he
came and kicked him
and then he fell down after that right
and ended up hitting his head
so you can see it but when you have
those skills
and you're fighting against someone like
that and it most likely that's all
you're going to need
and then the reality i mean it's not
like we're fighting every day on the
street and we don't want to also
be the one who instigate fights and only
if you have to defend yourself
and this is what martial arts teaches us
anyways right and it's that's actually
very interesting
that the what martial arts teaches us is
the same thing that
the sunnah teaches us the prophet
wasallam
um
[Music]
prayer learning about islam reading
hadith
just things like that this podcast that
would be one right because they're all
you know intertwined two would be diet
three would be training
four would be sleep and five would be
connections
social life keeping you know everything
straight with people
you know roommate if you're married just
these things
but that's just me that's time
management for me yeah subhan allah
that was amazing that's life changing i
have to implement that insha allah
yeah i feel like
i feel like god was speaking through you
because
yesterday man like i was uh making dua
after my prayer and i was just like
allah like just please
give me the ability to just be receptive
and like see what needs to be done next
like give me the the the ability to be
receptive and then
the ability to adapt and just like start
doing these things
you know because it the big changes are
obviously the big changes and
like bro i'm i'm just shocked
that like you were saying everything it
was just like then you just mentioned
the mma thing that
it all was just lining up perfectly bro
like it's like all these gears in my
head were like
just clicking perfectly bro so jessica
jessica let her bro oh yeah bro i
i appreciate it and here's the thing
quick side note is if you're in a
position to help
anyone don't don't turn it down because
you could be
the answer to that person's prayer
i i thought your wife was driving i was
like we're in the masculinity these days
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to the
realest podcast in the game t3m
we are joined with your host fayad angel
and rami and we got a very special guest
today sheikh abdul rahim
mccarthy salam alaykum
so off the rip i found you through a
video
online uh 54 lessons or 56 lessons
something like that
from khabib right that muslims can
extract and learn from
so i know the non-muslims and muslims
alike when
habib was uh you know fighting mcgregor
they were they were all you know rooting
for mcgregor i know muslims personally
including ones in my family that were
rooting for mcgregor because we didn't
really know too much about habib
and when you know obviously he took the
dub everyone was like yeah yeah it was a
big moment for muslims worldwide
people get on the bandwagon then right
yeah 100 they're just they're just side
switches
and you know what what what you see in
you know trash talk in pregame is
mcgregor has cultivated this air of you
know
being infamous and just notoriety and he
does have a big mouth
but when you see habib it's like he
didn't really get that recognition
too much from the mass media before
because he was he was always kind of
quiet always kind of stoic just
in his own lane something very
interesting about that you know i i've
started a new program on my instagram
and on my facebook
and have you seen it dirty lives now i
thought about i said no that before when
i was at the imam of the masjid
every day we would have you know live
reminders we mostly spontaneous things
after salah fajr a lot of the times
that's when i have my most energy
and sometimes you know in the evening
time from there as well i'll give
another reminder and sometimes you know
we'd
realize and just explain that
so i started giving daily reminders now
after a fajr i pray five years and it'll
be hour after fajr or whatever
uh and alhamdulillah we've been like
seven episodes thus far
so what the the topic i was actually
going to talk about tomorrow tomorrow
morning in chiang matana
was the issue that due out they're
facing
and it's very similar to what you
mentioned now i never thought about that
aspect
and that is the ones who do the trash
talking and like mcgregor when he was
getting
in a mauled by by by khabib at the end
of round three says it's only business
you know it's like lighten up everybody
you know because
it's only business it's to make money
but that's what you know that's what
people want and that's what sells fights
so that's why they have the trash
talking boxing is very known for that
uh whereas you know mixed martial arts
or martial arts in general and there's
something
you know a true martial artist and they
they stay away from that you find that a
true martial the artist that they're
usually
very humble even mcgregor the people who
know him before he used to be you know
very humbling
and he seemed to be a pretty nice guy i
know brothers who train with him in
dublin things like that or they had met
him
and he before he was famous and then
everyone praised him
but the trash talk thing it it it gets
money it gets views it gets publicity so
the same thing now that we face as duat
if we start to refute or respond
the amount of views that we have it
really goes up but if we come and we
uh you know talk about we explain a
hadith we explain the ayah
you'll find that people you know some
people who are you know want to know
about their dean they're going to start
to talk about it
you know so the like the main topic that
i have
if you look at my youtube channel in the
beginning i wasn't really that active i
started to be more active now i'm done
on youtube channel
um the highest views that i have
was a video i did about conor mcgregor
which was
why i hate conor mcgregor because i'm an
irish muslim who loves jesus there's
been a long
title but then that was the title i just
did it when i was sitting in a hotel i
was on a lecture tour in the uk
and i thought about as i was leaving my
house and i had an irish flag someone
gave me as a gift
actually took it with me and i i put it
on as well but people are here you're
not irish you know you can
you you have access my blood is irish
but
my accent obviously is american because
that's where i grew up
so the point is that was like on my
youtube channel it was 113 000 views
um whereas on other channels it was like
you know
one i sold like 300 000 on 300 000 here
there
so it got it got close to a million
views on different channels that was
just
for that video with that type of thing
which that's that's what the people want
to see
um the one about khabib was the second
one before which was
like 13 000. now the other day that
about mufi mink with the knitting and
all of this
that came in and in second place on my
channel because these are the type of
things that
any people want to listen to so what
does this tell the day any this is
really any
any because the objective don't don't
get me wrong because maybe there's
someone who's giving dawa now it doesn't
mean that he wants the views
but he wants to reach a larger mass
because that's more agile you know
we're we're doing that marketing and
things like this now because
and we want to be able to reach a larger
mass to benefit more of the omen shalom
ta'ala
so one might think that you know if i'm
doing things like this and i'm getting
the views
this is the direction i'm going to i'm
going to go but obviously i know my
objective
from my work and from my channels you
know it's the you know to educate the
ummah and to give reminders to myself
into the ummah that's that's
that's my objective so i mean every now
and then i might do some things which i
find are beneficial
uh i've talked about khabib several
times because i found that there was a
lot of benefit in that and i noticed as
well
that many many people don't realize and
we were mentioned before before we went
live you know this issue about
uh you know many imams don't want to
talk about the issue and because the
aspect of you know hitting in the face
and things like this being haram so
we can't take the talk about this we
need to leave it
and and people i know but for me
you know from the teachings of the
prophet sallam uh oh it's a hadith but
it's it's the the
authentic this hadith that i'm going to
mention it's not actually authentic the
island but the
but the scholar said the meaning of it
is correct and that is
which is the wisdom is the lost
belonging
of the believer and it belongs to him he
said wherever he finds it that he takes
it
so we can find good anywhere you'll see
it like a lot of time on my twitter page
and
this i might mention a quote in a like
for example john wooden
the famous ucla basketball coach i
really love his quotes you know so i
have a lot of his quotes i wrote down
sometimes mark twain nelson mandela
malcolm x
or wherever i find it you know it
doesn't necessarily have to be someone
who's muslim
if i find something that's benefit
beneficial or quote i'm going to quote
it because
it's something as a reminder for us and
something for us to benefit from
so always i mean this is what i try to
do myself and i call others to do as
well
many times in my khutbaz i remember one
time i i
i stood up on the member i was given the
khudban ireland and i said today's
khutbah
is coming straight out of hollywood and
i just saw the you know the faces of the
chachas the uncles and everyone there's
kind of
everyone just kind of looked up like you
know what's what's this dude going to
talk about today right
and something from hollywood but what
had happened is that robin williams
you know the famous hollywood actor you
know the the star honestly one of the
the best actors of all time here someone
who had killed himself at the age of 63
committed suicide
why'd he do that that's an amazing topic
for us to reflect on someone who reached
that status that success but yet took
his own life
so that was my hotbar and and i went in
on that so when i saw the the issue of
khabib
and you know leading up to the fight
with mcgregor
there was many uh lessons that we
started to learn about his life many
things we didn't know
wait i'm an mma fan i train in
mma myself so i knew who could be was
for a long time
you know and and i was a fan of mcgregor
before
you know what happened in the video
where i mentioned about when he insulted
jesus
and obviously turned me against him and
i said to the brothers right away i said
that
he's going to be humiliated and i
mentioned
that just like it happened to the
titanic which any also
it the last sailed out from from ireland
as well you know
and that's when when they met their doom
when they went out in the atlantic
subhanallah but the the point is is that
just like what did they say they said
that even god can't sink it this is what
this was their claim
even god can't seek the time that's how
strong it was so when he said the things
he said about jesus i said he's going to
be humiliated in the same way
and sure enough nate diaz on short
notice you know humiliated him in the
in the second round choked him out man
pretty bad as well you know
and he so in the same thing so i knew
who could be was and i was always a fan
of because he really liked his style
and and how strong he was on the ground
the ground and pound and
really really impressive and so but i
didn't know a lot of it about his life
so i started to learn more and more
about his life and i said you know what
i said there's a lot of things that we
can
you know benefit from in his life
because if you look at the issue
you know uh generally speaking most
people who have reached that fame
most people are professional athletes
who are muslims they're a bit
yeah you know they're not really serious
about their deal there's a couple of
them
or there's some of them who are about
you know they have some good aspects in
the dean but they still have some
you know wishy-washy type things you
know uh
some dodgy stuff that they do but you
know generally speaking they have some
good you know
we can give several examples and
probably several of them popped into
your mind when you just say that
but when you look at khabib and he looks
like someone who is very serious about
his religion and he has a lot of
beautiful stances that we can benefit
from
so that's when i just started to sit
down and start to jot them down and i
remember one of the
the duati he approached me he said hey
if you made it seven or something like
54 is a bit too much
but i found myself i kept going and
going and i and i can see that you watch
the video because the title i think it
says 54 right
but it's actually 56. so i mentioned the
two more i had it you know
i thought about at the end after i
prepared the hope and i added those two
so it was actually it was actually 56
and and like we said a lot of the times
people see the issue of what's happening
you know hitting the face and things
like this
that you know because that part of any
we know that's something haram in islam
therefore you know they completely you
know wash everything away they block
everything that even the good that the
brother has
that we don't take from that we can't
benefit from him because he's doing
something haram
and that's that's one aspect that's
haram but there's many other aspects
which are
permissible and even the prophet it's
been
confirmed that he wrestled so it's
something that's recommended you know
martial arts to be able to defend
yourself to be strong
the strong believer is more beloved to
allah than the weak believer as the
prophet
the prophet when you look at him as a
man as a physique
how he was described and if you were any
any i know you guys are into
um you know working out and things like
that you know what is
the main thing that really makes the
physique really stick out
and there's several things but maybe the
two main things
would be the broad shoulders and
having a flat stomach and that's you
know you're gonna have a top physique
when you
when you when you have you know broad
shoulders and you have a flat stomach
when you look into the physique of the
prophet salallahu said this is what he
talked about he had a flat stomach
and his shoulders were were abroad so
this is any any
and he was strong you know tomorrow
standing in his 60s with the battle
armor
on the battlefield in battle that's
something that's not easy
most of us probably couldn't even walk
with the battle armor now and nowadays
more or less then he fight with it on
and he would race with his wife
and even when he was when it was older
and his age so he was someone who was
very strong
and even as they mentioned in some of
the hadith when they tried to to
to break uh the big boulder that they
had found when they were
building the ditch that the that he uh
none of them were able to break it but
the prophet that he said to islam when
he came and he swung down
he was able to break you know
riding on the horse without the saddle
you know any rushing into danger
you can see that the prophet said to
islam he was someone who was who was
very strong and we as we mentioned he
wrestled
and he a man by the name of uh
and he was someone who was like
undefeated no one could beat him but yet
the prophet sallallahu alaihi washington
beat him in wrestling
and he thought it was a fluke and he
said okay let's do it again let's bring
it back
so he did it again and he beat him again
and beat him again and so he beat him
three times so
it shows you know that the the strength
of the prophet
that he had that's something that we all
need to focus on now the issue of
hitting in the face
because this issue comes up all of the
time and we talked about
a little bit about that before uh with
you guys
the origin of it is that it's haram
and it hit in the face therefore to be a
full-time
you know mma fighter you know when you
do it as a living
that would make it hard however like i
said about khabib and other brothers
i'm even friends with some brothers on
facebook and who are famous mma fighters
and you know i always say that's between
you and allah subhanahu wa
you know the ruling so that's between
you and allah i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna come in
and sugarcoat it for you because you
know i'm a fan i'm gonna say it's
it's that part of it is haram just like
i mentioned about uh there's a video
on my channel watching ufc hello
watching in in general i believe it's
any because you're if you're
someone who trains you're benefiting
from different things different moves
different techniques
and even when you have someone like a
commentator like like joe rogan who
and the other ones who know what they're
talking about and they're telling you
explain the moves to
if you're someone who trains you can
really benefit from that so there are
benefits
in watching it's not just you know
entertainment as one might think
there are benefits alhamdulillah and
watching but
what about the ring girls i mentioned
this in the video i know if you guys saw
it or not
and what about the ring girls what about
the the female fighters
okay and if if you guys were to watch
the the next ufc was it was it 259
three title fights how many of the title
fights are held out for us to watch and
how many are not
huh
yeah can we watch the nunes fight is it
permissible for us not this we have to
we have to turn it off with a minute we
have to cover it up or something it's
not permissible for us to watch
something like that even though you mean
as an mma fan and you're hearing
the commentary about this someone who's
supposed to be the greatest of all time
and it's going to be
intriguing for people to watch but
here's where we have to know our
boundaries that as men
as muslim men we cannot watch that
there's no doubt about that
but the um the heavy the light
heavyweight
uh israel and sanya however he promised
his name
uh that he is you know his fight we can
watch that
and also the the was the battam weight
one as well that's permission the other
one something we can watch this other
than the female fights and then when the
ring girl comes
uh make sure you you cover up you know
you know she's coming
so if you want to listen to the
commentary listen to the commentary we
know she's coming and then they start
calling her by name and things like this
you're not looking
she gone and she's gone and she's gone
and then she's gone and then you then
you watch the fight from there and shawn
otana so this is what you know
we need to focus on but it comes a hit
in the face now training here i take a
different approach
i believe in training and sparring if
you're not sparring with someone who is
an idiot
you know because you have to you always
have that idiot in the gym right i
remember we had a guy who visited us
and we were training in qatar and he was
like
um some pre-son or something like this
and he seemed like an okay guy
but the guy was just like you know leg
locking everyone and he's a white belt
you know and you're not allowed to leg
leg lock on your white belt you know so
you
as as white bells and him being away but
no no one's expecting to be leg locked
you know but he's been doing his
homework on the leg locks you know
and he's he's yeah he's getting
everyone's like what are we doing man
and
he almost hurt a lot of us honestly
because so if you have someone who's
who's sparring like that he's coming
full force at you then you can't train
with someone like that
but if you're just regular spoiling when
you have to you know get out of the way
because like
the brother mentioned that if in a real
life situation if you're not trained to
be able to move
then you're going to get hit and and
then you might just freeze
like the brother thought i froze earlier
in the conversation i was sitting there
i was looking at my notes he said did
you freeze that he thought i thought i
would froze on the screen huh
because i was reading so it smelled like
the it that's what's going to happen
when you get in the real life situation
you're going to freeze because you don't
know how to move and i remember when i
used to train with my coach in ireland
in an mma gym there that you know he
would
he would let me know you know obviously
we're going to train like this and use
what you have to do
if i moved the wrong way the fist was
coming this way i got hit
but i mean it wasn't hitting me like
knocking out my teeth or breaking my
nose something like that but i got
i'd get hit in the face if i didn't if i
didn't move fast enough and
so this this type of sport i think is
okay in chinatown i don't think there's
any big deal with that
but it has to be something you know not
not too hardcore where you're gonna get
hurt or you're gonna damage the face and
obviously if you can wear headgear
i just you know a bit of extra
protection as well i think that's fine
inshallah tana
to train like that but going all in no
this is something
because you can damage the face and then
you you fall into
the things i mean even it's light
sparring sometimes you can get scratched
up a bit but that can happen
you know all the time if anyone who
trains jiu jitsu
you're gonna find that you know i'm not
training these days obviously with my
knee injury but if i if you if i were to
take off my shirt you'd find
you know all my arms all bruised and you
know pinches here and
it's all black there and that that's how
the arms are
and even like when i look at the old
pictures you see all you know all the
bruises there
even i was doing japanese jiu jitsu it
was even worse because that was a lot of
throws you know
so we would i'd come home you see like
all my back and this and the side
it's all bruised all the time but i'm
down and you didn't really feel it and
you kind of get used to it but that's
just
the the battle scars that you kind of
get it get along the way
there's no problem with that so every
now and then you could fall on the mat
as well and you could hurt your face or
something like that
but inshallah so it's not any it's not
an issue inshallah
on hell how do you feel about that what
is that well
there's a lot going on
me too man so my question i got a
question for you
um would you not see the uh benefit of
hard sparring periodically
if there was an injury in it and that's
the thing because you don't want to
injure you don't hit the face hard you
know that's that's the thing
and it also it also depends as well and
he you're talking about
you know regular people and everyday
people
you're probably not going to need that
much of it and it's not some light
sparring
might be better and interesting enough
who was it the last fight were
watching was it max holloway who stopped
sparring all together huh
yeah but that's it but he went through
that period yeah
he was sparring like almost every single
day exactly
so like the whole reason i bring that up
is because
life sparring technical sparring is
beautiful
i'll be the first one to say that i love
it because it really shows you like
okay he's throwing this jab i can slip
i can move out i can counter
i can bring it down hit him with the
cross there's so many things that you
can like
it's more of a mental aspect to it but
then when it's like
in a real life situation the other
person is not gonna
do light and technical the other person
is not gonna
uh not strike to your face and not try
to hurt you
that's true but but don't forget that
most
of the people on the street don't know
how to fight
and most the people on the street if you
were to just get in your stance
and and just and just dance around a bit
and if you especially if you're someone
who's in good shape and you train
you're going to find that within 30
seconds you know them trying to throw
haymakers and not hitting you
that they're out of breath anyways you
know if if you know two minutes in and
they can't hit you and they're
frustrated with
throwing these crazy haymakers and you
don't know how to fight they're not
going to be able to hit you
and and and most haymakers with the
training that we have even if it's light
sparring
we're going to be able to either you
know to to to you know keep the distance
away or maintain distance or
to close the distance with ease upon
them and if they throw where you can go
them you can take them down get up get
on top of them usually jiu jitsu there
so the things that we that you have and
on the street anyways a lot of things
go out of the window but then again a
lot of other things could be used
if you look for example and i'll give
you a good example of that
um i think all of you saw the video joe
rogan talked about on his podcast one
time
uh the guy was there in the parking
garage and the guy was trained properly
trained
and he was uh what he did he started
going with the leg kick you know the leg
kick now and he
and and and he was in his proper stance
the dude
was the mexican dude yeah yeah yeah yeah
the dude he was fighting with was smart
he understood that that leg kick hurt
and the way he threw it
he realized that this guy is trained so
he was like he's he backed off and he
said
he basically he gave in didn't want to
fight and that guy respected that
but then the big dude who was smoking
the cigarette you know took off his
shirt
to one let that one let's drag up the
cigarette didn't know how to fight you
could see
when he went with his feet the back way
and what happened right away when he
came and kicked him
and then he fell down after that right
and ended up hitting his head
so you can see it but when you have
those skills
and you're fighting against someone like
that and it most likely that's all
you're going to need
and then the reality i mean it's not
like we're fighting every day on the
street and we don't want to also
be the one who instigate fights and only
if you have to defend yourself
and this is what martial arts teaches us
anyways right and it's that's actually
very interesting
that the what martial arts teaches us is
the same thing that
the sunnah teaches us
he said the strong one is not the one
who can wrestle someone
he said he's the one who can control
himself
at the time of anger so beating someone
down is not the one who's strong one who
can control himself is the one who's
strong
and and all martial artists and many of
them
as my coach used to tell me he said they
they tell you don't use it on the street
he said because it doesn't work a lot of
the traditional martial arts you know on
the street really doesn't work
but he said when he was on mma obviously
it works on the street but like my coach
said he said someone said something to
me
he said right away he said within the
first few seconds
he said i've seen seven ways i could
take this guy out
right away he said i could do this this
this i'd hit him like this i could take
it down like this
you know he said i know i could really
hurt this guy he said that knowledge
knowing that i could do it he said it's
enough for me he said i don't have to
actually implement it
but he said if someone comes to me he
said that's gonna be a different story
if he throws at me to something
different but if he just talks
i might say something back i hold my
ground i'm not gonna be a punk obviously
but he's not going to instigate the
fight but if he said if someone swings
at me i'm going to take him out
and you know something very interesting
that um he awarded one of our
uh one of the the kids who was training
with my son um he was a
you know he was a polish boy and you
know had moved to ireland
and you know he was you know has a
little glasses on they look cute little
boy mashallah but uh
you know maybe the bullies picked on you
know sometimes the guy with the guys
with the glasses and
they look like a little nerdish or
whatever so any
i mean there's nothing wrong with having
glasses but you know how kids are
sometimes you know so
the point is is that he was getting
bullied by this kid his family had
brought him to train
when he was training my son there you
know for about a year
in the gym so he knew his stuff so the
guy came in he just he grabbed him
did like a you know a proper takedown
and just to take down
got on top of him you know mounted him
controlled him hit him a few times
when he was in full mount made the bully
cry now the bully thought it was a fluke
came back later for a second dose
got the same treatment you know got the
same treatment from the boy
did the same exact thing to him again so
what happened he said no
if you were to go some some of the
traditional arts and the dojos around us
they would have been very upset that you
used this on the street our coach he
said no he said this is what we train
you for when someone attacks you
that you put them down you put them in
their place and he said therefore we
made a celebration for him
for him for all the other kids to see
and any to applaud
him for his bravery and for standing up
for himself because this is what we want
but this is the only time we're going to
use it so it's not like
it's not like someone who um you know
or you're going to have fights on the
street a lot and if we were to be honest
any
how many fights have we have you had on
the streets in your life any when you're
younger maybe more as you get a bit
older
you know you can become a bit more wiser
you're able to kind of you know
de-escalate the problems a bit more with
a bit of hiccum and things like that but
you still have the ability
if you have to do it that you're going
to do it and you know
i've ran into several cases you know
here and there but nothing
ever came out came out of it but i think
with the basic skills you have
then that's going to be enough there's
another scenario for for the sparring
if someone for example is a soldier
someone's he's a marine he's
you know special forces or are just in
uh
in the military whatever country he's
from here you might need to do something
more with that because
that's the person's gonna be on the
battlefield right you know so that's why
you see sometimes the marines and you
know people in the army and things like
that
they might train a bit harder and here
you might you might go full out sparring
sometimes like you mentioned
because here that obviously these people
are going to be on a battlefield they
could
you know come face-to-face combat just
like when we studied um
uh japanese jiu-jitsu i mean which is
the original jiu-jitsu many people don't
know that
i didn't know it either i went to the
the the jujitsu club thinking i was
going to be training brazilian jiu jitsu
they said that's something good when
you're in your 40s it's on the ground
it's pretty it's it's i mean it's not
really that i would say it's easier but
uh
anyways maybe you can do it for longer i
guess once you get good at it
so but i found myself getting thrown
around all the time like i was in a judo
club you know that
but then i realized it was actually
japanese jiu jitsu what is the origin
but if you study it
what is japanese jiu jitsu it is the art
of the samurai warrior
they came up with this art that they
lose their weapon on the battlefield how
to defend themselves
with their hands so this is uh you know
for soldiers they need these things even
i was debating recently
with some brothers about the issue of
using steroids
and is it something that is permissible
in islam
i personally believe if you if someone
is is doing it um
in a way that is you know not overboard
like the bodybuilders who do you know is
that obviously too much and that
definitely can be harmful if you do
anything too much you know it can be
harmful
if you drink too many pepsi's a day that
can be harmful uh if you have too many
donuts it's going to be harmful right
so all of these things are going to harm
your body if you do it but if you have a
pepsi every now and then
a donut every now and then it's not
really going to hurt you if you're
eating healthy and you're exercising
that wouldn't that wouldn't harm you um
so many if somebody and if you really
study in detail
and the harms the things about steroids
why it's so because it's forbidden you
i don't know if the laws are in canada
maybe it's more lacks and i know in
europe it is especially using
uh selling it's not but i think the user
you're allowed to use it in europe
but can't say that's my understanding in
most countries the point is is that
if someone is using it you know
that an aspirin is more harmful i mean
if you want to be honest
than steroids in a lot of cases so i
mean it it doesn't it doesn't seem to be
that dangerous
um so it could be permissible is it
something we recommend though we say no
and if a normal person why would you
want to use peds it's never really not
any most people don't eat it maybe you
get a bit older you might need a little
testosterone or something like that
that's that's some trt that that might
be different but
a younger brother who doesn't really
need that
he but then again i gave the example if
someone for example special forces
soldiers who know who go behind the
enemy lines that gives them the extra
the extra push because it doesn't have
to be someone who's you know is jack
these huge who uses
look at lance armstrong for example
right yeah he was how skinny he was
and he was using pd's right so this is
something in any and i think the origin
of it
it's not something that's haram but it's
not something that's recommended there
could be harms for it but someone were
to need it
and even some cases like for example for
recovery if you look like uh
you know anderson silva after he he
broke his leg and i don't know how long
it was like he was back like it was like
eight ten months he was back or
more more or less uh but he recovered
too fast
you know that that's not natural an
injury like that to recover fast
and then you know miraculously he gets
busted if you know after the thing for
tested positive of course it is there's
no way he could recover that fast
without you without using something but
here to recover from injury like that
there's no problem with that so i need
to see any of these type of things
and they look at it from from the whole
scope and maybe the general people say
no but
there might be certain people who might
you know benefit from it and could use
it in certain cases a lot of those best
there's a lot of nuances and i learned
that with a video i saw a v-shape with
uh i think it was islam 21
and you mentioned very clearly it ties
into what we were discussing prior to
this
that the people that really know how to
fight they don't go out of their way to
start fights
it's always the people that really don't
know how to fight that are ready to
throw hands
exactly and you can see when they throw
hands they don't know what they're doing
most of them you know
right from the forum and that that is
someone who's who is trained
that kind of you know makes you relax
you know like they gave the story of the
mexican guy in the girl when he kicked
you know this is a problem now because
this guy this guy knows what he's doing
right
but and he's someone else who's throwing
the haymakers and stuff like that you
know that person's never trained
doesn't know how to hit doesn't know how
to fight and he's going to most likely
going to burn out in
within a couple of minutes anyways i
don't know
i don't know romney you see you said
your phone battery's low
yeah my phone's dying but there was a
question i want to ask
just in case it does die i can watch it
back so
young men muslim men should learn how to
fight correct
of course to know how to fight to know
how to defend yourself
is something you need to be in shape and
work out
this is what we need to be in is we need
to be encouraging our youth to do and
the thing is with our youth today
you know you look at the reality of the
youth there's so much free time there's
so much free time that they have
and so much negativity that can be put
in that faith and that's what's
happening
they're sitting in front of devices
they're getting fat they're getting out
of shape
they're watching things they shouldn't
be watching so this is the type of thing
that we should be encouraging them to do
and honestly when it comes to i'll tell
you a story
very interesting um when one of the best
islamic schools
which was in india the school of dr
zakir naik was established
you know they came to the physical
education department what do we do
so they went to some specialists and
from the people they asked for advice
was uh phillips said you know what
should we do you know dr
he's a black belt so they he they asked
him what should we do
and he said well you can do what most
you know
they do in arab and muslim countries
which is to let them play
soccer let them play football right so
they can have very strong legs
so when the enemy comes they can run
away fast huh
he said or you can teach them something
that will benefit them
which is martial arts
and subhanallah i want you to look at
something very important it's not just
the issue
of the confidence that it gives them the
i guess that's the dead battery huh
uh looks like it the the confidence that
it gives
them oh no he's back the confidence that
it gives them the strength that it gives
them the clarity of thought
uh the strength in their body when you
have a strong body of a strong mind
it puts their their their time into
something productive
instead of it means something and that
that's not productive um
and i remember when i was when i was a
kid you know it was totally different
i mean i would i had all the devices you
know we had first we had atari then we
had
nintendo then we had sega and
playstation stuff wasn't around xbox
wasn't around during my time
but i had all of those things but i
rarely play with them you know rarely i
would play with them why
because i was always outside i was
involved in sports i was riding my bike
i was active outside
that's that's natural how a kid should
be the situation they're in today
is not natural for a child to be in that
situation uh to be in front of a device
to always be in the house
to always be you know cooped up like
that the one of the beauties of martial
arts as well not just for that time
frame when they become older as well
now the difference between martial arts
and other sports i'm not saying i
encourage any type of sport
which you know they put their the
they're using their body it's better
than wasting their time in front of a
device honestly
my son for example wants to play
football i don't really i'm not a
football meeting soccer obviously in
this part of the world
i don't really uh you know i don't
really like it i'm not really a big fan
i want them to go to the dojo
but if that's something they want to do
and there's only they train some martial
arts then they have the ability to
it's no problem with me they're free to
do that if that's what they want to do
um i think our brother i think his
mother was there with him he asked the
question about the
martial arts i thought i heard in the
background so almost the man should
train martial arts huh
i don't know if he was asking for his
mom and she was hearing
what was the issue there so i heard i
heard some people talking in the
background and he was asking
and what i was saying is that the
longevity of martial arts
you'll find that many um jiu jitsu
practitioners
and if you look for example the guy i
don't know is his um
his real name the actor al bundy we call
him i don't know if you guys before you
guys age you know the
uh the bundys or whatever the tv show is
called anyway he was out bundy anyways
in the tv show
i was like it was 80s or 90s i think it
was so he's now i think he's like 70 or
something but he's a black belt and he's
he's still training jiu jitsu
uh dr billard phillips and he black belt
still trains
and he's still in very good shape on
mubarak uh husseini
black belt still trains and and in good
shape
so martial arts there's there's a type
of longevity where you can do it how
long can you play basketball for
and he had tomorrow really for like a
health benefits i mean
you might pay some play some pickup
games in your 50-60
but the thing is you you can continue to
go to the gym you can continue to lift
weights when you're 60 70 80 years old
if you continue to do it obviously your
body will stay strong in this
you continue to do the martial arts and
to a level obviously
and then you you'll see that many people
in the very old they're still rolling
still doing jiu jitsu
they're still doing martial arts because
the the body can handle that something
natural for the body so
for the longevity of of the by
health-wise
martial arts also the best thing we can
do and to teach our children
and well i i wish the the time and the
effort
that i put into basketball when i was
young i mean i i i enjoyed it i really
loved it i'm still you know
a big basketball fan i rarely play
unfortunately
but um you know if i put those
in hours and hours every single day if i
put that into
learning on martial art you know where
would i be now and i could still be
using that
i could still be using it even even till
today alhamdulillah so i think this is
what i think the main focus for our kids
and it should be something like martial
arts if they have other
inclinations where they're inclined to
play other sports i think we should
support them in that as well
if they're doing something that that is
you know productive
and um you know because their time is
just being wasted and they're sitting in
front of their devices and
it's ruining them and the the the
founders of apple steve jobs
uh bill gates of microsoft and it then
they said obviously
in the in the reports or the stories the
articles that they wrote about them
they say that they only allow their
children 20 minutes a day on the ipad
they're the ones they're the ones who
created this
and they're the ones who limit their
children but yet we give our children
unlimited access they sit there for
you know they might sit there for 20
hours a day some kids subhanallah and
what is that doing to the to their brain
how is it ruining their brain especially
the younger ones it's even worse
obviously
uh what is that doing to the development
the brain and the hormones doing to
their brain
and um you know not doing something
that's really productive
for them online so we really need to
focus is very very important
for and also it creates a form you know
of masculinity as well where they're
going to be strong
as well and i think that's also we've
you know talked about that before
um and you've talked about some of the
other guests as well that's a very
important aspect or something that's
missing
you know being a registered being a man
uh that's missing
in the lives of of the boys today and
then but even the girls by the way i
think
the girls is very important for them to
train as well and if you look on my um
if you look on my page um i've talked
about this
or even like on my instagram page
there's a picture of matching geese one
one for me one for my wife and she was
training as well and you know
i should be doing more with her by
training her as well to
be able to defend herself one of the one
of the the projects we have i haven't
been doing a good job of it but it's one
of the projects
that we have is training with her we
have the jiu-jitsu mats at home
and things like that for us to be able
to train at home together alhamdulillah
and um even i i i did a video about
uh our sister and he who is the the wife
of our coach here in qatar
who is it was it was the first any
nekobi black belt
in in in brazilian jiu jitsu i did a
youtube video about her something
amazing
lazy accomplished so even our sisters
need to learn because any it's not all
the time
where the husband or the brother is
going to be their defender what if
something happens what if she has to
defend herself
and wouldn't that be awesome if you know
an akavi sister you know she got in her
stance
and that happened before i also posted
this on my page as well it was an akavi
says i think she put a key in her hand
or something like that
and she beat up this dude who was trying
to attack her and his face was all
messed up it's like this
and she was an akabi sister hijabi
whatever she is
but the point is is that you know being
able to defend defend herself if she
needs to
very important also it's going to keep
her body strong because a lot a lot of
even
a lot of the the marital problems that
we have and we we counsel is
a lot of times the sisters get out of
shape the sisters
they're not in shape the sisters that
you know that they don't take care of
themselves
because they're they're not exercising
they're not training just you know it's
just the house the kids the house the
kids
dealing with it with the husband you
know so she's she's she's busy with all
of this
and she's not taking care of herself
right so any but but if she can train as
well
a couple of times a week it's going to
help her stay in shape it's going to
help her you know deal with the stress
it's going to help her be able to defend
herself if she has to as well
yo i don't know aren't you just moving
out right now
and the amount of knowledge and wisdom
well i i did want to i love the wisdom
by the way i love it
one thing that i did want to say though
is you were saying about uh
people on the streets not really knowing
much and like if you learn a little bit
well you're pretty much like ahead of
them and it's like i get that
but at the same time like if you only
learn
technique you only spar very light
like this is the average joe this is
where you're at
you know like you know more you've
trained it
but once you get in the situation of an
actual fight
and again it's not that we're trying to
go for a fight it's not that we're
looking for a fight
but if a fight occurs that little bit of
a
edge that you have goes away because
you've never experienced the pressure
of being in that real situation where
it's like
in a hard sparring session again not
something that is
feasible to be done every single day but
if it's done periodically it
shows the individual what it's like in a
very controlled environment
that pressure in a situation like that
to where
okay you may never use right we may
never use it in our lifetime
but it's better to have something and
not need it than need it not have it
you know what i'm saying yeah but if any
if you look at
the train that most of us do it includes
jiu jitsu
and to we go pretty any some might go
100 when they when they roll
some might go like 70 percent and like
uh
you know faro the happy who's there with
you guys in uh
in canada and that's his philosophy is
it and not to go 100 so you can roll
more obviously
so i mean depending on how you roll but
nonetheless even if you roll 70 percent
that that's pretty that's pretty you
know full on you know you're going out
yeah yeah
for sure but that's that's just did
as they say most fights end up on the on
the ground and then at the end what do
you want to do
and yeah bjj is is is the best way to
obviously i think for self defense
and then if you add to that obviously
you know just some regular grappling
uh you know striking you know these and
obviously if you're going to get some
mutai in there as well those type of
things
to be more more well well uh
well-rounded
if and don't forget that where is the
strongest who are the smartest
the best fighters are the smartest
fighters and obviously
the strongest asset that the war has
where is in the mind right so this is
the strongest the strongest thing
so if you can control yourself and you
can be focused at that time this is what
you have
this one has to has to click in and
something very interesting with that
in the hadith of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
a lady she was crying over the death of
her son at the grave
and he went to adviser and she didn't
know who he was she didn't look up you
know
she knows the problem she was like you
know get away from me who are you to
advise me right
and the people when they saw it and then
the process said he went away you know
and then the people said you know who
that was that was the prophet
and she was like shocked i couldn't be
so she raced behind him
and she said you know that uh you know
for the advice thank you
and i'm going to be patient and he said
a very valuable lesson to her for all of
the ummah
he said innama and the that the patience
the real patient where does it come it
comes at the time of the calamity when
it hits
that's when you judge for the patient
but if you freak out and start throwing
things and then
you know a couple hours later sometimes
you calm down and tell them you can get
rewarded for that but
the real reward you've already lost that
because you weren't patient at the time
so the same thing now is that you have
to be intelligent
right away as we mentioned someone who
knows how to fight thinking
you're not going to want to fight
anyways this isn't i'm not really
entering fighting but if he starts to
come
then you have to you know what is the
key thing now it has it has to click
in the key thing now is for me to
maintain the distance to get it
let him wear himself out it might be
close quarters i'm thinking now because
as you're talking
i'm thinking outside of my hotel room
here for example i'm in a situation
and that's happened before i remember
there was um
i was walking with my son and um
i was wearing my throat my islamic
attire and i was in london it was one of
those
races like skinhead guys and all the
tattoos and he's looking at me like this
and i'm just like
i'm just trying to control myself you
know but that that was a close quarter
no one was around it was a hotel room
the floor upstairs
you know it's like it's going to get
broken up there's nowhere there to break
that fight up
and not quickly anyways so this is you
might need
as you said in that situation i can
understand where you're coming from
but i still can't see that i think it i
i do believe
it's going to be enough it's going to be
enough the the basics that you have
you know you're ruling full force in jiu
jitsu um you know
you're sparing your boxing like i said
you'll be you're gonna be able to read
if he's throwing haymakers you're gonna
know how to deal with it
and if you train for those situations i
think inshallah it's going to click in
and sean you're going to be okay
and at the end of the day if someone get
you with a good one even if you're
someone who's trained
you can still go to sleep can't you huh
yeah yeah
but the thing that i want to shed light
on here is um
you said all fights they end up going to
the ground but they say they say a lot
of this
they start they start standing up here
it starts standing up
and like i want you to understand too
like brazilian jujitsu
also spoiling that now there's no
striking in the face at least
inherently like you're not trying to
strike someone in the face you you're
trying to do submission you're trying to
locks you're trying to do cranks
stuff like that so if you're sparring
right if you're rolling with someone and
you're going like 10 20
right very light very technical you're
just doing it so you can like see
openings you can learn how to
uh escape defend uh pass guard and all
that stuff right
if you do that if you only train at 20
and then let's say
a situation arise but now you have to
roll like bro
the person might not know anything about
rolling but
the fact that you've never actually
tried to roll with someone who's
who's alive who's moving like yes this
person that you're rolling with they
know what they're doing
so they're also going to try to uh
play this game of chess with you you
know what i'm saying so like you both
are going 70
you both are playing this game of chess
with each other you get someone on the
street they don't know this game of
chess
you know the game of chess but you only
know it from a 10 to 20
uh standby point so now you get with
them on the ground and you
you're in the moment you you're not
going to be able to think clearly
because you've never been in a situation
where you had that much pressure
yeah i i don't know bro i mean look look
at look at the other videos you know
online where people who just had some
basic jiu jitsu
and they put it they put it to work you
know arm bars
uh you know chokes and it just just
stuff any
i'm just i'm just thinking about video
after video that i've seen
where people have used it like you know
really strategically on the streets
and a lot of them trained for it that's
the thing yeah yeah they're training for
just like we would
in in in the gym for jiu jitsu because
at the end you roll this is the thing
about jitsu
it's the same thing you're talking about
striking you you roll and a lot of
people are rolling with you they're
rolling 100
maybe if it's if it's a more advanced
belt yes they're going to be a
bit more merciful with you i was i was
looking at i just posted a video i was
training in 2019 on
my instagram and facebook uh it was just
a little uh
i compiled you some of the videos i was
a bit slow a bit but i'm learning
obviously
but one of the videos where i didn't
post mail post in a couple of days
i was rolling with my coach he's a black
belt and he's a professional mma fighter
as well
um he um he had my arm
you know and it's just like you would
think that would be something
you could get away from back i couldn't
get away from him and i'm moving
everywhere
so he's just having fun with me on the
map right he understands he's an
advanced and he's black but he's a
personal mma fighter it says i'm a white
belt trying to learn the you know the
basic techniques so and
he just grabbed my arm and i just
couldn't get it i couldn't get it away
from him
so someone at that level obviously
they're not going to go full force with
you
but other other white belts and things
like that obviously they're going to
even some blue belts
they might pick you apart a bit as well
and it says but so you're going to
you're going to find that
you know they'll they'll go uh they're
going to roll with you and it'll full
force a lot of them
so this is so you're going to have that
you know that training especially
if you train a lot and i think it just
because it's it's um
the the you know what they call it the
muscle muscle memory memory
muscle memory yeah muscle memory where
it clicks in
that's how jiu-jitsu works it's just
it's just repetition repetition
repetition
after you're doing all that repetition
it's it clicks in automatically
how do you know when you're going to
escape how do you know i need to how to
you know to pull guard to you know to
get out of someone's guard
it's just that that repetition of doing
it time and time again
the training the techniques and then
implementing it on the mat
so then on the street any and most
people
like for example and how to get over
someone's guard and to get into side
control
any that's something that used to be
difficult for me but then
and it just opens it starts to come
natural how just how to slide over and
to get into
get into the slide control and then to
lock him down so he can't get out
i'm a bit of a bigger guy so i know how
to use my weight
a bit more and i started to see i could
use that more and more to my advantage
as as i started to learn more so
alhamdulillah and then once you start to
learn those things
they'll click in inshallah yeah but
look i'm respectfully disagreeing or i'm
respectfully just trying to shed light
on
uh this perspective here like am i right
am i wrong that's
that's for the creator to judge but i'm
just trying to shed light on you know
and like again what you're saying like
it's all true if someone learns the
basics of jiu jitsu if
fire begins to learn the basis of you
just give him a few months
and he's going to be able to put someone
in a lock on the street if something
were to happen
but that comes from the training that
comes from the repetition in the
training in
the rolling the sparring and that
sparring like you said
the the higher belts they'll go easy on
you because they already know what
they're doing so they're just kind of
playing with you they're trying to work
their technique
you go against another white belt you
guys are going almost full
force yeah you know so it's like that's
where you learn
that's where you you develop the uh
it's called subconscious skill but mind
my muscle
connection uh muscle memory but it's
it's subconscious skill where you do
something
in a situation so much that it just
locks in and you just know how to do it
without thinking about it
where it's like okay well now if you put
striking in the same light
like well then it makes sense if you're
going full force
in jiu jitsu and you just you can go
full force more often because it's
it's more forgiving and people are more
understanding but if you have the
training partners
in striking that are also very
understanding and they know
you know it's not an ego match you're
not you're not trying to win
this match against this person but you
guys are legitimately training for
training purposes i myself
see a very big benefit in this
for the person to develop that
subconscious skill that muscle memory to
where it could
i i agree with that situation as long as
it's not too hard i was like i said from
the beginning
i don't know it doesn't have to be like
light sparring okay you can be like
proper sparring that's what i'm talking
about when i said in the beginning
but it can't be you know like you know
like a slugfest this is what i'm saying
but if it's something that's you know
i'm not talking about just like you know
light taps and i'm like no
if you you could properly spar i think
you know and sometimes
i mean the for the more technical type
of sparring that would be the thing you
would probably do more but if you want
to do it
a bit more full force sometime i'm cool
with that i have no problem with that
but obviously it has to be like you said
the the the condition has to be
with a partner who's understanding who's
not like my coach i was like
if i didn't move the right way my
coaches hit me in the face but he's not
gonna hit me in the face where i'm gonna
have to get stitches in my lip each time
where i'm gonna lose a tooth
you know where i'm gonna have a broken
nose and a black guy each time he hits
me no
i mean it hurt i mean i'm getting in the
face i'm not gonna say it didn't hurt
you know but
but that that reminds you once again
that when that
this way you have to move that way
because it's coming that way and then
any of these i have to move back i might
have to duck now
duck under you know th this is the thing
so this is the
like you said you're not going to be
able to learn that if it doesn't come at
you and from
from the heavy bag and just you know
shadow boxing you're not going to be
able to learn that
that's true i guess the reason i'm
i feel so strongly about this and um i
speak
in this light or in this way is because
you know i'm not just
going into uh professional fighting for
money or for fame or
anything like that or for ego it's more
so like i want to learn the ins and outs
i want to know
what really works you know i want to
know 100 what really works and
if i have to go through these situations
in the most controlled environments that
i can possibly get then
alas i'll do that just so i can teach
other people and show them what really
works that
one thing is i never want to lead
someone astray if i'm showing someone
self-defense
i don't want to show you something that
when the time comes
you go to use it and it doesn't work at
all
yeah that was ed if you saw the the part
one of the podcasts
our brother father zabi did with one of
the muslim brothers in the uk
when they talked about this issue that
was the logic that he used as well
any but i mean like i said i think
you know that question has been answered
and which one is the because
he said which one is the superior
martial art
you know but i mean i i think you have
to join all of them together i don't
think it's enough to have one obviously
and i say it's then it starts standing
so even if you're if you're good on the
ground
if you don't have a standing game if you
don't have a stand-up game then any
obviously
even the grappling to be able to take
someone down um
you need that ability to take something
to be able to use your ground game more
so you need to be well-rounded obviously
and you need to know all of our i mean
if you're someone who's specializing in
it then obviously you need to go deeper
than
than than someone who who's not and even
myself that's one of the things i have
uh
i have a private coach where i train
with the duggar stanley brother
and so i enjoy the private training i
learned the techniques but i
i realized i mean i got injured at the
end so i had to you know take some time
off
but i realize in the back of my mind
when i go back i have to get back on the
mat how to start rolling again
which is you know something especially
in the beginning when you're going
people more
advanced and it's it's it's a big
challenge and
most people quit jujitsu in the
beginning because you just get you get
smashed in the beginning and then
you even you might you might know some
martial arts but you just get completely
smashed
but then when you start to learn a bit
you know you have someone else that you
submit
um i remember i was training with one
guy he was actually much bigger than me
um and he but he was more consistent i'm
always traveling with the dow and things
like this so i can't be
as consistent as i wanted to be as i
want to be so
i mean he had heard a few stripes on his
whiteboard and i still i still don't
have any stripes you know
uh i i got up to in japanese dude so i
got up to yellow belt
and i became i was qualified to become
an orange belt which is the third level
uh but i traveled during the exam time
so i couldn't take my exam but i i
definitely would have got it shallow if
i
if i had stayed but when it came when i
came to the japan to brazilian jiu jitsu
i trained mostly mma more than i changed
and then i trained with the
star train with nogi here so it was like
the ghee training i wasn't enough but
when i came back to
the dojo when i was training with him he
was much bigger than me and i was
probably
like 130 kgs it's a big guy but i was
able to hold my own you know even though
he had been consistently training
and i even i saw him one time when he
couldn't get me off of him because most
people when he would jump on them be 130
kgs he would just pull them down and
like ragdoll them under the ground but
he wasn't able to do that to me you know
even though he outweighed me by about 30
kgs
and then i was able to get on top of him
he struggled a bit with me as well
thinking he would be able to be the
bigger guy
he would be able to um to uh to to be
able to
to beat me easy especially because now
he's more advanced but obviously
that for me and just you know some of
the other match when you start finally
start to win some things
wow you know after i've been smashed you
know six months everybody
everyone beats me you know they have
these little guys just like throwing me
around and then i started to realize and
like you said it starts to come
i'm like how can this guy who weighs
like 65 kgs
throw me around like i'm i'm a doll you
know like really just like
i'm in the air and then you start to
realize that when i come around like
this i have to
just put my weight down a bit like this
to the bottom he's not gonna be able to
throw me like that
and then you start to learn and starts
to come natural okay so then and it
starts to become more enjoyable at the
beginning obviously that's the that's
the challenge
so anyone who hasn't trained before you
hear a lot about jiu-jitsu
like the first six months that's that's
the real challenge and i know for myself
now when i get back on the mat and i
haven't trained like over a year
you know covert hit us and then you know
hurt my knee had surgery you know still
recovering i don't want to get back on
the madness i'm like oh back to
not zero zero i have some experience and
i you know i have some knowledge
but just the muscle memory is going to
be gone and it's getting it back
it's going to take some time it's going
to be another challenge but it's it's
fun i enjoyed it
before we end this episode ramy had a
question before he
left that you know all that being said
how can we start
learning mma what can we do as parents
kids
um maybe if we never got taught and how
do we start now
where where do we go from here you know
i think you know it's not difficult to
learn you just have to start
uh the the biggest challenge like i said
it's it's going to be difficult in the
beginning
any it's especially something like jiu
jitsu where you
realize you you have to have in your
mind that you're going to get smashed in
the beginning
okay and i remember there was um a
brazilian dude i trained with like the
first time i ever went or first or
second time i've
ever rolled in brazilian jiu jitsu
um he was a black belt
in in judo and i think he was very
advanced in in brazilian
maybe like a brown belt i think he's a
black belt now
so he got me into a choke and i mean i
don't think he meant to
to put it on that hard but it's just
like you know
like and the thing i'm like i'm a public
speaker too so i need my throat right
you know
and like for two weeks i could feel it
you know so many people with an
experience like that wouldn't want to go
back
and then one of the worst feelings
honestly
when you train jiu jitsu is having
someone on top of you and not be able to
get them off
you know and then so the feeling of just
getting humiliated you know
it's something that's not easy in the
beginning so it's a difficult journey in
the beginning
but just like anything in life if you're
going to start with mma you have to
start
you know find a good dojo wherever you
are
some might just be bjj so you might have
to go somewhere else
and if you look if you don't find like a
a true mma gym
then i would recommend doing bjj and
then maybe doing some
some multi or some kickboxing uh
and mixing between that even you could
do some boxing as well um if you have
the kick boxing
along with the bjj i think that
inshallah will be sufficient obviously
if you could then add to that a bit of
you know grappling
i benefited a lot from my coach the
dougas danny
and he's a brown belt in in in brazilian
jiu jitsu
black belt in japanese jutsu and
obviously the wrestling is just and i
think part of their dna they do it since
they were
they were ki their kids mashallah and i
know you guys saw the video with the
little kid when they were throwing the
punch the other day
it went pretty viral but if you look at
the four man just over it's like wow
it's really good man so it's like
something i don't know
did his father trade how to do that or
just something he has and
my sons they started with uh with mma
along with bjj depending on where we
were in the world um
they started with uh sometimes they were
four four years old they started
both of them two or two of my sons i'm
there somebody's older sons they're
they're starting now but these ones they
started as they were four obviously the
driving force behind that
maybe the original was me along with
their mother but their mother was the
one who was always taking them
their mother was the one who found uh
the mma gym
in the local area were living in ireland
and even because i benefited a lot from
the coach i became very close to him i
did a lot of private training with him
and the dojo as well so she would always
remind me of that you know that
i'm the one who found the gym you know
so we all benefited a lot
you know from training there and a very
nice guy very respectful guy
benefited a lot from him alhamdulillah
so it's just it just starting
and getting on on the mission and just
anything in life
just as you you you just put to put it
put into action
let the ball start rolling and just just
do it as nike says it was just
how cliche it is but that's the reality
is that you just have to do it you have
to start
and you have to be consistent anything
in life it all comes with the
consistency
and i remember that you know i could
show you guys some pictures when i
started like like losing weight and i
started training
um some of the best shape that i've ever
been in it's always when i'm consistent
when i'm not consistent i kind of you
know you'll see like especially
anyone when you look at your physique
you might have some strong areas here
and there so that might remain
but the other areas they kind of you
know you kind of lose your gains here
and there you don't you don't see it
when you when you're consistent that's
when you when you when you see in
the the true benefit inshallah so just
start be consistent
find a good gym inshallah and
alhamdulillah one of the
the beautiful things with you know many
of the people in the west
is that a lot of them they're very
understanding i remember i took my son
to start with taekwondo
and the guy was like you know really
militant into the system and
the issue of bowing and things like this
i was like look we're muslims my son
came about
and this is in ireland he was like no he
said we can't you know he said we're not
doing out of worship he tried to i mean
he was nice and the way he explained to
me and try to you know try to convince
me but i wasn't going for it
but when we went to train like japanese
jiu jitsu
we want to train mma the respect they
had in japanese jiu-jitsu
there's bowing and there's prostration
there's sujud
but our coaches made for us a special
tahiti a special salute because it was
me and some
early brothers who were training there
uh which would just they would do like
this
instead of doing the bow to each other
when they would train with one of the
muslims
they would do like this you know and it
wouldn't suit us like this
at the end when they would do their
sujud we wouldn't do it we'd sit down
like the same thing like you do in salat
and things like that on your knees
but no when they would make their sujud
we would sit as muslims we would make
sidhu you know
and i remember one time we had this
coach he was on the ground he was a
beast he was amazing on the ground no
one could
ever submit the guy he was an older guy
and um
he uh he got in you know he went through
like this life change
he became vegan you know even though our
coaches itself he became
much weaker in his body after he became
vegan and he couldn't really do as much
as he could before subhanallah
and then he became buddhist so they go
through like these these these weird
changes some people
so he's like to do some meditation at
the end of his thing and he he came and
says okay if i do this
and you're here with us sitting down at
the end i said you do your meditating
your meditation
and i said we have something called the
vikir the remembrance of allah i said as
you're meditating
i'm going to make i'm making this be i'm
glorifying our creator
i'm saying subhanallah alhamdulillah
i'm repeating the vicar as he said you
do your thing i said i don't do mine
does it doesn't
doesn't matter i'm not going to worship
with you you do your worship i'm going
to do mine
alhamdulillah and they were very
respectful of that alhamdulillah even
the mma gym as well they were respectful
if every now and then when we would
train the a woman would come
even our in japanese jujitsu the the
head
of our dojo she was uh it was actually a
woman but she didn't come all the time
she would come with the kids
and her husband uh he was three dan
black belt and he was she was five dan
so she was the you know the supervisor
she would come
especially for the grading and things
like that but when she learned that
um you know i don't train with him and i
don't touch women
i don't shake hands with women you know
she had a lot of respect for that so she
if she wanted to show me something
she would bring in one of the other guys
when she would come in and she would
throw him on the ground and
get him in a submission and show me how
to do it you know she wouldn't touch me
it wouldn't ask me to to
to to roll with her and and she would
come in sometimes there was another
lady sometimes who would come from
another another area
and you know when it came time to roll
you know they knew that it was my turn
to roll with her i was gonna roll with
her
they were very respectful of that even i
remember when i took my son
uh abdullah to train you know and and
for the first time japanese jitsu he'd
been doing mma since he was four as i
said
when i took him there i forgot to tell
him about the bowing stuff and i left
it was really cool because the the the
coach she came over to him and she said
abdullah you're not going to do this he
said we're going to do this at the end
of this
so you just sit here normal she
explained to him that you're not going
to do this that's amazing
so you find a lot of them you know even
though they're non-muslim coaches
this is the point i want to point out
many of them are very respectful and
it's important for us to respect
ourselves first of all as muslims
that we have principles we have values
and we explain to them open say look
i can't touch a woman who's not my wife
you know i can't roll with a woman
um i i know i can't do certain in
certain
any uh like in in in brazilian jiu jitsu
they don't have it like the issue of the
uh the different type of of
and it's more like shaking hands and
things like that and us and all of this
instead of you know subdued and and and
what have you there are some bowing some
do a little bit of bowie it depends on
the jojo you go to but if you explain to
them um
that they respect that and that's a
beautiful thing
of most of our communities in the west
where you have those individuals if you
find someone who is
you know not willing to compromise
something believes in then you don't
train with him
and you move on somewhere else inshallah
man i also see the opposite shake where
people are ashamed to
you know share their values and be
different and appear as a muslim
you know they try to you know compromise
their values and their integrity
and kind of come with this you know half
treading on water
moderate type of theme where you know
they wouldn't have done it somewhere
else but they're like oh no i made it
here you know i don't want to make a
scene i don't want people to
call me out and look at me as different
yeah this is this very very common
and not just with the youth even with
some of the older brothers and sisters
who are very any fearful of that whereas
what they don't realize and i think a
lot of the times i mean
unfortunately some of them have been
born and raised in the west but just
they have this
this this you know type of mentality or
this uh
you know where they don't have a
confidence in their self and their
religion
what they don't realize is that people
respect those who respect themselves
people respect those
who have values and they stick to them
even if they disagree with them
even if inside they hate your values
many of
the people i'll tell you when they see
my wife and their club they don't like
it
but when they see that she's a person of
values
who values her religion and she does it
out of her own
you know any religious any contentment
and commitment that
she that they respect this
even i've found that there's more
respect for like when we go to the
embassy to renew our passports
many of the time i found that the guards
and the staff that they were more
respectful with my wife and her nikop
than they were
with with the women who would come in
you know trying to be the modern
muslim ladies with a half hijab and all
the makeup on and the high heels she
can't walk and stuff like that so she
looks like she's modern and cute
right and you'll find that you know that
the way they were treating
wasn't relaxed but with my wife they
were very respectful for of her
because they it's natural people and
people just i don't know how they don't
get this
that when you have respect for yourself
and your values people will respect you
and also that gives you a sense of pride
and honor
where you feel like you're someone who
has principles who has values
that you hold on to and that's that's
more valuable for me
i remember when i we opened the islamic
center in ireland
that the mayor of the center of the
excuse me of the city
she was you know a lady
and when she came and she put her hand
out to me
to shake my hand i was the only one who
didn't do it
the other brother who was in charge of
the masjid
beard islam he's given
like oh man you know so i'm the only one
here looks like the the crazy dude now
and
now i'm the extremist right because i'm
not shaking hands
but what i did i explained to her and
she she was a bit shocked she was a bit
caught off guard to balance with you
but she came back to me and started
talking to me it was really good
and even i remember one time one of our
islamic exhibitions
uh and another city that the
second in the police force in our city
was it was a lady
and she had another lady with her and
she came and
she came to shake my hand and then i
didn't explain to her
she was like that's cool she i didn't
know that she said this is something we
have to teach our officers now the irish
are really cool people by the way i
really
really enjoyed my time in ireland you
know with the local government with the
police we did a lot of good work with
him
so they and it was very interesting what
she said she said we need to put this
into
our curriculum where we teach about
other people
we teach about other people and their
values so they know that
a muslim man who was any someone who was
you know they might call you orthodox
they might go whatever it was
you know devotee who's practicing
whatever terminology they're going to
use
but they said that they will know if you
see someone who's a practicing
and he does he doesn't want to shake
hands it's not disrespecting the woman
and
it's it's because of a value that he has
when it comes
to principle and then the issue
of the nihab she can start talking to my
wife he said also we need to talk about
this an issue of
uncovering this if a police officer
comes what is the ruling
and she said could you your wife come
and talk i said of course i said don't
i'm not gonna
and this this is a principle i always
took with uh the issue of the hijab
i was asked to speak up with hijab and
one of the universities and our lord i
said no no i said if you want a speaker
let one of the sisters speak
uh about her hijab because me you know
the beard
it's the the mullah who came you know
the the extremists who come to
to you know to to put the women to put
them down and to hold them back and make
her wear
this garment over her head and over her
face and it but when a woman comes and
speaks
you know even i told my wife as we
travel i said
if you don't want to uncover your face
to the man in the booth
you tell him not me because one time i
told him i was like can you bring a man
the guy looked at me like you know
oppressor you know
so i was like i said look i said if you
want to uncover your face to him and you
want a woman to come do it
i said you ask him next time i said i'm
not i'm not going to say anything
something that she does it herself and
and even in some countries out of
respect
i remember one time we were traveling um
we're actually traveling to denmark
unfortunately i think they banned the
nikon there now
uh but uh as we were traveling to
denmark
we were going through holland so we came
through the the the passport control in
the middle
in amsterdam we actually didn't enter in
hollywood just crossing through but
that's where the border control was in
the middle
so the guys themselves they called you
know the the woman for my wife
also in the uk a lot of times when they
see her coming within a club they call
the woman you know so they they got used
to how did they get used to that
by the women who respected themselves
and respected their hijab
that she had values so they realized
that this hijabi woman now has
values therefore therefore they
they started to respect her and her
values as well and this is something
muslims just don't get it man and and
and
it makes it easier for all of us when
you respect our values people start to
learn them and start to know what they
are
and it's going to be easy for us then to
practice but if it's like what i said
when i was the only one at that islamic
center
who didn't um who didn't shake the
mayor's hand
and how did that make me look and how
was that but if if all of us were doing
it becomes second nature
now in my city in ireland when it comes
to
uh the islamic exhibitions when the
mayor came
the new mayor came and he said to me it
might be an issue for me to shake some
of the women's hands he said i found it
in the report
because the last mayor wrote at the
islamic exhibition is what it was he
went down
down his notes so the new mayor he read
the notes of the old mayor
and he realized that there might be a
problem shaking women's hand
some of the the muslim the muslim women
might not feel comfortable
so he came and he asked me as the as the
imam of the city
he said you know is this the ca and i
explained to him i said if she doesn't
put out her hand
that means she doesn't want her she can
you see this she doesn't want to shake
hands
but if she puts out her hand to you you
can shake her hand and she doesn't she
doesn't have that same value as the
other one does
but then you see now because of the
implementation of some of the brothers
and some of the sisters there's a form
of respect alhamdulillah
and from from the from the people from
the society because they start to learn
but if everyone's scared to act upon
islam people are not going to know what
it is and you have
the one you know lone wolf mosquito who
who's trying to implement it you know
he's he's he's he's the
the black sheep of the flock or the one
who's outcast you know he's the outcast
of the group because he's the only one
who's trying to that's the way they look
at him anyways
but he's the one that's the prophet said
that's what's important
is that you know islam started strange
and it will return as something
so peace be the strangers so we take
pride in being from the strangers
even if we're the only ones who act upon
it inshallah that was one of my favorite
hadith and uh
muslim it was it was straight up and so
glad tidings to the to the strangers
because at the end of the day we live in
a society where it's not too far from
jihadi
so you know but yeah
so i know do you have anything else for
this episode
your question in the beginning before we
even started
or i think maybe we did start i don't
know you had said the
the hadith about striking to the face
um i don't know if you said it was uh
a hundred percent authentic or like
questionably authentic which one was it
no no no the hadith that i mentioned it
was questionably authentic that it
wasn't authentic
was that the uh the the hikmah the
wisdom
is the loss be lost be uh belonging of
the believer wherever he finds it he
takes it
so the hadith is not authentic but the
meaning of it is authentic as the
scholar said
because when you have a hadith it's
broken down into two parts
the island and the mutton the islam mean
the chain of narration
from the author of the book all the way
to the prophet
and then the second part of the hadith
is the text meaning the saying or the
action
uh of the prophet soloism or the
approval of the prophet saws
in that hadith so if the chain of
narration might be weak
but the meaning of the hadith goes with
in accordance with other meanings in
islam some of the scholars might say
that
we can benefit from this hadith not
saying that it is hadith that's the
difference you wouldn't say the
prophecism said this
but it's interesting we can benefit this
as a principle as
as a benefit uh as if we can benefit
from that
that's what they said about this hadith
because it's it's a beautiful meaning
but the snat is not authentic the chain
iteration is not authentic
however the hadith of hitting in the
face that is authentic it is authentic
we're
you're not allowed to hit into the hit
the face
i hope this episode cleared some stuff
about the nuances behind the hadith and
the modern day
elegance yeah all right so if you guys
made it this far
type in hashtag dojo and
thank you so much sheikh abdullah
the time to be featured in this episode
until next time guys
[Music]
you know you can do this without school
you already know that you can bring in
money
now the question is can you bring home
some paychecks and show that to mommy
and daddy
can you prove it that you can do it
because at the end of the day
they still have this traditional eastern
philosophy that you need to go to school
we came here we sacrificed our life
for you to go to college so you can get
this degree and
make this money whereas bro i keep
preaching this
you don't need school if you don't need
school if you're not trying to be a
doctor you're not trying to be a lawyer
you're not trying to be
some type of engineer i'm talking about
an actual practical engineer right
not like a programming uh you know
software engineer that can
that's you could do it from your laptop
bro now
these types of things go go to school
but you don't need one to be a software
engineer
can you be a software engineer through
school of course
can you be one without school of course
so why take the route that you might
have to
indulge in the ribba in interest in
student loans
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
hmm